Yeah. Which brings me to the one thing
that I wanted to get to before we leave.
This is a waterboarding.
Yeah. And this is,
this is something that came
up because you were defending,
what does her Gail, Gina, Gina, what
does her name has bell hospital.
And she is the person that was
being appointed by to lead the CIA.
Yup.
And there was a bunch of people that
were saying that she shouldn't be because
she advocated torture and you uh,
to defend her,
decided to um,
get water
boarded.
Yup.
We've actually been talking about this
for the past hour and a half. Yeah.
We have, we've been talking about, um,
the slow erosion of,
of the human condition.
US getting softer and US getting
weaker and US getting, um,
norphine the edges and finding the
easy outs and the easy solution. Um,
the conversation of middle ground,
finding a way that we can communicate
with people and have a discussion. Um, we,
so we've been, we've been having this
discussion for the past 90 minutes and um,
what I have is a bunch of people
that are sane what something is,
but they don't know what that
is. Man. I know what torture is.
I've seen it in Africa,
I've seen it in South America,
I've seen it in the Middle East.
I've seen it on almost,
I'm pushing 20 trips overseas
in a military capacity,
a handful of combat deployments,
you know, from looking for poachers,
human traffic, gears, drug
cartel, um, kind of piracy,
the things that I have done.
Like you want to talk about
knowing intimately what torture is.
I fucking know what torture is.
Pouring water on somebodies face is
not torture Kate. If you starve them,
if you beat them, if you isolate
them, if they're there for, you know,
you're the only getting the yes, we can
start adding things onto it. But the,
the thing that was the most irritating
was everybody's just throwing out this,
well, let's talk about morality. And this
woman is immoral to be in this position.
I remember people jumping to their deaths
on nine 11 because they didn't look at
burnt alive,
right?
And then I saw a guy on his knees and
have his throat slit open by somebody's
pulling his hair back and sliding
that knife across his throat.
That was one of the guys
that she interrogated. Not,
I'm not saying two wrongs make a right,
but she interrogated them to get a
question, to get questions out of them,
to try to save more Americans.
The intent was to try to save more lives.
They say, okay, well if it's not
that bad, then why did it work?
And this is why.
And this is what nobody understands.
And it's because they can't understand
the difference between the easy way and
the hard way is that because these people
that we were waterboarding are cowards.
They were pussies. They're impotent
little bullies their whole entire lives.
If I put you on that water board,
I could waterboard you for days.
You have your moral convictions and you
would never change cause you believe in
what's right and wrong and that's a great
and beautiful thing. They're not you.
They are pieces of shit that that throw
acid on little girls that flood planes
into buildings because it's capitalist
that that's who these people are.
And if they're only tough when they're
surrounded by 60 70 other of their
friends, but you take one of them
away from that and you put them in a,
in a position where they're powerless
and that's what waterboarding is.
The powerless and they cave
and they cower in seconds.
Like I don't need to drive
a nail through their hands.
I don't need to pull their teeth out.
I don't take a drill bit and drive it
through their fingernails. That's torture.
This is us pouring water on a cowards
face and they freak out and people can't
understand that because they can't
understand what these people are and their
animals, the, the, these,
these aren't beautiful religious people
that are trying to do the best thing for
the families.
These people were the worst of archive.
These were the Nazis of the 1940s but
this is the current version of it in the
these radical fanatics that are doing
anything for any reason to hurt anybody so
they can feel better about themselves
and you take them out of that power,
they take them out of that control.
You take them out of that opportunity
where they can be the bully and they're
just shadows of themselves and then they
give you everything that you need and
what you need is an opportunity to
save more lives. Well, there's two,
two things that were discussed about this.
One,
that your situation that you were in was
not in any way similar to the situation
that they were in because you
were doing it with your friends.
You knew you were going to be okay.
You willingly did this. The the,
the whole process was very controlled.
You, you weren't being held by people,
spoke a different language and a
a country that hates you. It's,
it's a situation where
you knew you were safe,
so you could relax yourself and calm down
and tolerate it to the point where you
knew that you, you would be okay.
Yep. And what was the other side?
The other side is if torture works,
isn't that the best form of
torture you're going to be? Okay.
I mean, if, if torture does work
and I don't know of torture works,
I've never been tortured.
I've never been around torture.
And I know there's a debate both in both
torture doesn't work. It doesn't work.
Doesn't work. So that's not torture. No.
So you think you feel like that works,
but torture doesn't.
So I think,
I think maybe we're arguing
about vernacular and verbs
or you're forcing someone
to do something they don't want to do and
you're, you're freaking them out. Yeah.
You're doing something physical to them.
So I think we just have
to define torture. If, if,
if it's me doing something to somebody
that makes them uncomfortable is torture.
I mean,
me asking a pointed question at somebody's
in an interrogation room down to LAPD
could be torture. Right. You know? Um,
if you smack him in the face as it become
torture, is that torture? Right? Um, well,
I don't know if I hit him with a
phone book.
Maybe the problem is the word.
Maybe the problem is defining
the word you're, I mean, they,
then they called it enhanced
irrigation techniques when,
if you're trying to get information
out of someone that would save American
lives, it seems to me, I may be ignorant,
but waterboarding seems to me to be
one of the most humane ways to do it.
I agree with that. You're not going to
do any permanent damage to the person.
It's not like what they did a John
Mccain when he was a prisoner in Vietnam,
and that disturbed the shit out of me
when that guy was on Fox News and he
called them songbird McCain because
he was, he was saying that, you know,
terrorism,
that torture rather worked on Mccain.
Like how could you stoop like that? I
mean, how could you do that? I mean, you,
you know what that guy's been through to
humiliate him and humiliate yourself by,
by, by taking that position on television,
like that was so disappointing.
It's
about usable information. We're, we're,
we're questioning and if you cross that
threshold of torture where you are doing
damage,
physical damage,
where they'll tell you anything that's
not usable information that you're going
to say that you've, you've been, you know,
dating your producer for seven years and
secretly like, I could get you to ace,
say anything under the right
conditions that doesn't do it.
You just want to stop the pain. Yeah.
Just anything to make it stop. Um,
that's not what was happening here. And,
and when we start talking about morality,
if they're saying, okay, if this
is a moral act, then then, okay,
this make me and all of my friends
that have done all sorts of tea,
some in some cases,
terrible things.
Are we now a moral people because we
did it in the interest of protecting our
country and serving our country and,
and providing protection for our freedoms.
And,
um,
I know those are cliche phrases that
people grab onto and I don't want to,
but it then by extension,
throwing and lobbying those
accusations at her extend to, uh,
to me and to the things that I've done.
And I think I'm a very moral person and
I try to be a good person and in every
way I can imagine, I'm
not perfect, I'm not.
But I try and the politics of
bleeding over and misusing words,
manipulating everything
just so it fits your agenda,
but nobody's in the middle of ground.
Nobody's agreeing and nobody
has the best interest at heart.
And that's the people like
the best interest should
always be serving the people
and none of them are doing that.
They only care about what is going to get
them reelected or what's going to give
them more power,
which can even more money from the lobby
or what's going to give them more clout
for the next vote.
What's going to give a little handout
from the president or what's, you know,
whatever games that play that happened
on the beltway. That's what the,
and that was an example of that in,
in the most horrible of ways
because it came down to human lives.
It came down to somebody who had been
serving their country since the 80s and
the best way that she knew how in the
ways that we're legal for her to do it and
everybody else just manipulating
the narrative to fit their agenda.
When I'm just sitting here being like,
how about the people and how about
freedom? Who's fighting for us? Is it,
are you guys just going to
keep bickering about this?
So me strap strapping myself to
that board. Um, I'll tell you,
it's harder.
Do what's easy is to lay they're strapped
and have somebody put water on your
face. Do it's hard. When
I did to Steven Crowder,
watch his hands where he'd reach
up and pull the, he couldn't have,
he couldn't take it.
He would pull the rag off his face.
See many times I pulled the rag
off my face, not once, right?
Every single time I said,
no, no. Poor longer. No, no.
Use the host. Use the bucket.
Right now you're at a two.
I need you at an eight now I
need CIA interrogation friends,
right? And I'm sitting there
willingly with my hands.
What the sensation of me drowning as
that water's running into my sinuses
showing that was intentional.
I understand. People are
like, oh no, he was safe.
He wasn't even tied down.
I did that to demonstrate how a man of
resolve can do it effortlessly and how
it's not torture because I could willingly
lay there with my hands free to pull
the rag off at any juncture. But I did
it. I just sat there and I asked for more.
I understand that,
but I also understand the position
that people take where they say,
you knew you were safe, and so this is
why you had that sort of resolve. You are.
You're not in enemy soil,
being interrogated by Isis,
being strapped down by them where
you didn't know what was next.
If you do think this, what would be
next? Let's say Rachel Maddow from MSNBC,
because we agree on so much.
If she's like, Hey, I want
you to come onto my show.
I'm going to bring in
five CIA interrogators and
we're going to do it live.
You're in control of nothing. Do you
think the result would be any different?
For me? Not the same, because you're on a
television show and you're still, you're,
you're Americans are going to do this
to you. You haven't been captured.
You're not an enemy soil. You're
not, you know, how far did on,
how far do we have to go?
You have to kind of be the person who's
really captured is really captured.
It's not a game. It's like
if you get choked out in the
street, you can't tap out,
right?
If you get into a physical fight to the
death of someone and they take your back,
you can't tap out. Right. And in this
situation, you know, you can tap out.
You know that even if it's
CIA interrogating you and
they're yelling at you,
there's a part of your brain that
knows I'm on Rachel Maddow show.
They don't kill soldiers on Rachel
Maddow show. This is true. Um,
so I don't know how I could
have better have illustrated.
I think you did a fantastic job.
I think the problem lies and
it's impossible to really
recreate it without you
being an actual prisoner of war.
Um,
do what we do a reverse the roles we're
talking about snatching these guys from
their bomb making facility in
whisking them to upgrade and,
and pouring water on their face.
What happens to me and my friends when
were captured? Oh, we waterboarded no,
no, no, no I'm not,
I'm not saying that what they do to
us makes what we do to them. Right.
But I'm saying is, um, it's better.
I'm saying it, it's better. I mean
since what I was saying before,
if it is shorter,
if you want to use the word torture,
like we'd use the word drugs,
right?
Drugs are coffee and it's also
heroin, right? They're all drugs.
Caffeine is a drug, right. Torture.
If you're just going to say torture,
I'll take that torture every day
because he knows what that is. Yeah.
Cause even if it sucks, yeah,
I'm going to be burnt alive.
I'm going to be steadily
right. Carefully, methodically,
painfully murdered.
Yeah.
And that's my only option there.
There is never any other option.
If I got captured,
there's no moral equivalency. I think
we could both agree there's no, I mean,
between us and them, there's
not, but here's the thing.
Mccain himself said that she shouldn't
be appointed because she willingly
participated in torture. He said that.
Yeah. The, what did you think about that?
I have one. Respect his opinion.
I, the things that he has done,
whether we agree on things
are, is irrelevant. His,
his resume speaks for a spell.
I agree.
And I think very few people could
speak to torture better than him.
I agree with that as well.
Um,
so him coming from that position and
saying that she isn't eligible to serve,
um, is a very powerful statement. Um,
I also feel that I'm pretty intimately
familiar with torture and that I
understand the full spectrum of,
of what somebody can do selflessly
for their country and um,
selfless selfishly for their own
satisfaction as a psychopath. Um,
like Zarqawi's enforcer that would go
around and kill people in front of their
own family members had carried
around a pat battery power drill.
And I saw that we tracked him.
So
I also know that when she was doing all
of these things for her whole entire
career, one, they were,
you have to look at the context of
the time and what was happening.
Um, and when she did every
single one of those things,
they were authorized techniques.
They were encouraged,
they were successful in some
degrees, um, to some degree.
And so she was trying to do the best
that she could in the, with the,
in some cases limitation that she had.
Um,
and I think that is a trait that I want
in somebody leaving the CIA that is that
they're going to do the best that they
can with what they have and what they're
allowed to do.
And
Aye,
I like that. Yeah. Muscle
bulldog. I realize that,
but this isn't someone who's
talking about this in the, you know,
the comfort of a board room.
This is someone who's dealing with it in,
in time of war and you're dealing with
some of the most horrible people that
we've ever experienced it or making
these videos of cutting journalists heads
off and sending them to their families.
Yeah. I mean this is, this is,
this is really what we were experiencing
when people were deciding to use these
enhanced derogation techniques.
This is what they were up against.
This isn't something that you
can discuss in a classroom and,
and get a full sense of the tone and what
was happening in these people's lives.
Nine 11 was the tip of the
iceberg when that happened there,
there were hundreds of other plans
to do similar things with Dev.
That one was just successful.
They had been trying others and
they have tried other sense,
whether it's a shoe bomb,
whether it's a Paris train,
whether it's a San Bernardino
bombing, whether it's a, a, uh, uh,
a garbage truck and France, you know,
or London Bridge. It's any, any, they,
they have consistently been trying to do
that and duplicate and replicate that.
The reason that it hasn't happened again
to that scale to that level is because
of the uncompromising selflessness
of Kiros trying to protect Americans.
Now, I don't want to go into what is the
greater good [inaudible] are we losing
morality coming? That's a rabbit hole
that we could talk about forever. But man,
I just want to preserve life.
Why do you think that concept
is so hard for people to grasp?
Because that's scary.
Well not just that,
but the concept that the reason why this
hasn't happened more often is because
of these people doing the heart hard
work.
Why is that so hard for
people to understand that
increase your skin hard work?
I just made a gut MTV show just so they
could see for the first time that people
work hard so they can have
food and they have work hearts.
They get of oil and
they power that people.
They look at a post when I don't have
a shirt on everybody says man tinted,
loving being off. You sorta. I've looked
the same since I was 19 years old.
I have looked exactly like this with
the same eight pack with the same muscle
definition since I was an 18 year old kid.
I don't even know how many times I've
been tested from the military for Usada
two different events.
I've been cleaned my whole entire career
but nobody can in their mind they can't
understand. To get from here
to there is hard work. No,
there has to be an easier way and it has
to be steroids or it has to be this or
it has to be that. It's the same way.
They're protected and they're safe,
but they can't grasp the idea of the hard
work that it took to keep them there.